bonjour à tous dans quelques instants
vous allez assister à l'audition de
laurent wauquiez par la commission des
affaires sociales le secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'emploi et auditionné sur le
projet de loi portant réforme sur les
retraites c'est le sujet de toutes les
crispations actuellement à l'assemblée
nationale où se jouent un véritable bras
de fer
le texte a été débattu toute la nuit et
ce matin encore les députés socialistes
vont tout faire pour prolonger l'examen
du texte la réforme des retraites va
engendrer des bouleversements sur le
secteur de l'emploi
si la réforme est votée en l'état le
report de 60 à 62 ans de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite va notamment
augmenter le nombre de seniors au
chômage tout de suite direction la salle
médicis
alors nous avons le plaisir ce matin
d'accueillir monsieur le ministre
laurent wauquiez secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'emploi sur le projet de loi
portant réforme des retraites
monsieur le ministre je vais vous passer
immédiatement la parole oui voilà madame
la présidente
merci beaucoup cher muguette dini de
votre accueil à la commission pour cette
audition sur un sujet qui me tient et
vous tient très à coeur il a également
remercié monsieur le rapporteur
dominique leclerc qui s'est beaucoup
investi sur ces questions notamment sur
les précédents passages au sénat où il
avait contribué par ses interventions
dans le cadre des débats et notamment
sur les articles portant sur les
dispositifs sur l'emploi des seniors à
faire des améliorations substantielles
alors sur ce sujet de l'emploi des
seniors sur lequel vous m'avez demandé
d'intervenir devant vous dans le cadre
du projet de loi portant réforme sur les
retraites
d'abord la première chose qu'on constate
c'est que incontestablement l'âge de
départ à la retraite a une incidence
évidemment sur le taux d'emploi des
seniors l'exemple qui est très frappant
en la matière c'est celui de la suède
qui a entamé une réforme des retraites
dès 1999 et qui à partir du moment où
elle a agit sur son taux de départ est
d'âge légal à la retraite a connu en
même temps une progression très
importante de son taux d'emploi des
seniors avec un taux qui a atteint sur
les 55-65 ans 70% quand la moyenne
européenne
elle se situe à 46%
pour autant cet argument n'est pour moi
pas suffisant il n'est pas suffisant
parce que étant donné la cristallisation
des mentalités qui s'est fait en france
dire que le seul fait de pousser l'âge
légal aura une incidence sur l'emploi
des seniors n'est pas assez et donc on a
tout un appareil de fond qu'on doit
entreprendre et qui a été entrepris je
fais revenir sur les résultats
permettant de changer les mentalités sur
le sujet permettez-moi de le dire très
solennellement tous les partis
politiques comptables devant leur porte
parce que nous avons trente ans de
responsabilité collective tous partis
confondus et personnes qui que ce soit
ne peut donner de leçons en la matière
qui a consisté à sacrifier constamment
l'emploi des seniors le raisonnement
était simple quand on s'occupait de
politique de l'emploi des seniors
étaient considérés comme étant une
donnée statistique qui encombraient les
statistiques du chômage et donc il
valait mieux pousser les seniors dehors
et ce raisonnement était tenu par tous
les gouvernements depuis le choc de la
crise de la fin des années 70 avec des
dispositifs tous plus imaginatifs les
uns que les autres mais dont il faut se
dire simplement quelle était leur effet
c'était de rose de sortir
statistiquement les seniors de nos
statistiques du chômage
ceci a fait l'objet die hard un espèce
de consensus qui a été relativement
partagé par trois types d'acteurs les
partenaires sociaux qui d'ailleurs le
reconnaît sans mal puisque bas quand il
y avait des ajustements dans les
entreprises ça permettait d'avoir du
grain à moudre pour rendre les
ajustements moins douloureux les
entreprises qui ont profité de ces aides
pour faire des ajustements sur leur
créera mythe d âge et baisser leurs
coûts de ressources humaines au prix du
savoir-faire de la compétence et de
l'expertisé des seniors au sein de
l'entreprise
et puis l'ensemble de la classe
politique qui a vu et depuis de trop
nombreuses années un moyen de faire
baisser nos statistiques du chômage
la réalité c'est que effectivement quand
on fait ce type d' approche
ça soulage à court terme et j'ai souvent
comparé ce type d' approche de la
morphine
ça soulage à court terme mais sur le
moyen terme ou le long terme c'est
extrêmement douloureux
d'abord parce qu'il ya un effet domino
vous commencez par dire qu'on fait des
préretraites pour les 58 ans mais du
coup une entreprise qui embauche
quelqu'un que si elle sait qu'elle a une
perspective de le garder et de louer de
pouvoir développer son savoir-faire et
l'insérer dans son équipe
elle considère qu'à partir de 54 55 ans
elles n'embauchent plus personne et puis
progressivement on a eu un effet de
contamination
on voit très bien que dans les habitudes
de redon bausch par le passé à partir de
50 ans ça devient très difficile pour un
senior de retrouver un emploi et donc le
raisonnement a été catastrophique avec
l'impact qu'on connaît sur l'eau taux de
croissance de notre pays et puis tout
simplement sur le financement de nos
différents régimes depuis trois ans
aucun gouvernement n'a autant fait en
faveur de l'emploi des seniors et c'est
pas seulement des mesures qui ont été
prises c'est des résultats et je vais y
venir notamment en termes de taux
d'emploi
d'abord la première chose c'est que nous
avons pris la décision d'arrêter tous
les dispositifs permettant de sortir
artificiellement
bonne lecture à tous le monde permettant
de sortir artificiellement les seniors
de nos statistiques du chômage
c'était le dispositif de dispense de
recherche d'emploi qui était quand même
quand on y réfléchit sur réaliste ça que
quelqu'un qui cherchait un emploi à
partir de 58 ans même un peu plus tôt 57
ans et demi se voyait adressé une très
belle lettre lui disant surtout restez
chez vous dans con
rep à nos statistiques de chômage ne
cherchait pas d'emploi on n'a pas besoin
de vous ce qui est enfin même en termes
éthiques et de liens entre les
générations
assez suicidaire et incompréhensible
s'ajouter à sa toux des dispositifs de
préretraites extrêmement coûteux qui
consistait à payer pour sortir les gens
du travail et du marché de l'emploi
alors que l'on verra il ya d'autres
solutions qui sont beaucoup plus
intelligente et qui peuvent permettre
d'avoir un accompagnement financier
parce que je pense qu'on en a besoin
mais de faire en sorte qu'ils permettent
de garder les gens dans l'emploi le
résultat a été et avec des périodes qui
ont été extrêmement importantes
notamment entre 1997 et 2000 où on n'a
eu quasiment plus de cent mille
personnes qui partaient en préretraite
et cent mille autres qui étaient
dispensés de recherche d'emploi chaque
année pour gérer les statistiques du
chômage c'est sûr que c'est plus facile
nous avons essayé de nous battre sur ce
volet d'abord avec toutes les mesures
qui avaient été portées par xavier
bertrand notamment le système de surcote
qui permet de valoriser les seniors qui
vont jusqu'au bout de leur carrière
je rappelle qu'il était à peine 5 % en
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 13%
d'essayer de rendre plus facile la
possibilité de cumuler avec des règles
d'encadrement très stricte sur lequel le
sénat avait d'ailleurs veillé le cumul
emploi-retraite de supprimer la dispense
de recherche d'emploi qui se fait
progressivement au fur et à mesure que
nous atteignons des améliorations en
termes de taux d'emploi des seniors et
surtout de changer le comportement des
employeurs en la matière ce que l'on a
fait vous le savez c'est que nous avons
fait peser une obligation pour les
branches et les entreprises de signer
avant le 1er janvier 2010 des accords
destinés à changer les habitudes en
matière de gestion des ressources
humaines à l'inter de l'entreprise et
d'embaucher ces accords ont notamment
été accompagné par le cabinet vigeo de
nicole notât qui a fait tout un travail
en amont qui nous a permis de travailler
sur les meilleures habitudes des
entreprises est d'inciter les
entreprises à travers des cahiers de
bonnes pratiques a misé sur une autre
approche des seniors
ma conviction c'est que cette vision des
seniors qui sera un handicap de
compétitivité dans l'entreprise et
totalement fausses
et que dans un univers où les
entreprises ont besoin de stabilité ont
besoin de compétences d'expertisé et de
savoir-faire
le fait au contraire de garder les
seniors dans la durée dans une
entreprise ça fait le socle la colonne
vertébrale d'une entreprise est une
entreprise qui se prive de son savoir
faire est une entreprise qui est morte
areva a failli succomber de ne pas avoir
su anticiper la transmission des savoir
faire dans le domaine du nucléaire et de
ne pas avoir su organiser la bascule de
savoir faire entre les seniors qui
avaient construit des premières
générations nucléaire je sais qu'il ya
ici un certain nombre d'entre vous qui
sont très attachés à ces questions et
d'organiser la transmission des savoir
faire notamment sur les jeunes
générations à tous niveaux et d'ailleurs
ouvriers encadrement etc au sein au sein
à un ingénieur au sein d'areva
donc on a fait peser cette obligation
tout le monde avait dit mais c'est une
catastrophe les entreprises ne vont
jamais pouvoir s'adapter et c'est la
réalité est que au 1er janvier 2010 nous
avons la quasi totalité de toutes les
entreprises et de toutes les branches
qui sont couvertes maintenant par des
accords destinés à favoriser l'emploi et
l'embauché des seniors est juste si vous
revenez deux ou trois ans en arrière
quand on négociait sur les seniors dans
une entreprise c'était savoir pour
comment les mettre dehors aujourd'hui on
a des vrais accords de branche et
d'entreprise qui sont avec des mesures
destinées à favoriser les embauches et
le recrutement en faisant sauter les
pratiques discriminatoires qui sont
destinés à favoriser l'accès à la
formation professionnelle
alors qu auparavant quelqu'un de plus de
50 ans avait deux fois moins accès à des
outils de formation que quelqu'un qui
avait moins de 50 ans ce qui aboutit
sert progressivement faire dépérir son
capital et sa formation personnelle et
puis tout simplement des accords qui
sont destinés à gérer les fins de
carrière en donnant plus de souplesse et
en permettant d'avoir des vrais fans
karner organisée au sein de l'entreprise
alors les résultats les résultats ils
sont intéressants parce que et en trois
ans sont des résultats qui sont quand
même significatif le taux d'emploi des
seniors a augmenté de plus de 5 points
ramenant progressivement la france dans
une comparaison européenne beaucoup plus
favorable
au total cela représente 300 milles
seigneur de plus qui sont en emploi par
rapport à il ya trois ans trois cent
mille seniors de plus à comparer avec
les chiffres que j'ai évoqués sur 97
2000 on était sur 600 milles seniors qui
avait été poussé en dehors du marché du
travail un taux de chômage sur les plus
de 50 ans qui est resté très inférieur à
la moyenne nationale 6,1 pour cent de
taux de chômage sur les 50 60 ans
chiffre qui je pense est important a
rappelé et enfin 80 accords de branche
qui ont été signés 33 1900 accords
d'entreprise et plans d'action qui ont
été adoptées et 12 millions de salariés
qui sont maintenant couverts par des
accords destinés à développer à
développer les pratiques internes
favorable aux seniors moins de 250
entreprises ont préféré payer la
pénalité
alors dans ce cadre là nous allons
essayer d'aller plus loin avec dans le
cadre du projet de loi qui vous
concernent deux dispositifs fondamentaux
le premier consiste à transposer pour
les seniors l'outil qui a le mieux
marché dans la crise qui a été le
dispositif zéro charge qui par sa
simplicité sa lisibilité a permis de
créer plus de 1 me de favoriser plus de
1 million d'embauchés alors même que
nous étions dans la crise et de faire en
sorte que pendant la crise nous avons eu
plus d'embauchés dans les tpe qu'avant
la crise ça a été un outil extrêmement
performant et qui va être transposée à
travers l'article 32 du projet de loi
aux seniors pour favoriser leurs
embauches se tient également à préciser
que l'impact contrairement à ce qui
était craint l'impact de zéro charge n'a
pas été plus de précarité dans l'emploi
mais ont contraint moins de précarité
dans l'emploi puisque le nombre
d'embauchés et le taux d'embauché en cdi
a augmenté par rapport à la peine
précédente où nous n'avions pas ce
dispositif
en parallèle nous allons également
favoriser la transmission des savoir
faire et le tutorat
c'est un outil auquel je crois beaucoup
qui est très important parce qu'il est
totalement à rebours de la logique
précédente de partage du travail qui
consistait à opposer les générations et
qui consistait à faire croire que quand
on se bat pour l'emploi d'un senior ont
fait perdre un emploi un jeu c'est
totalement faux et pire que ça je trouve
que c'est que ledit criminelle en termes
éthiques parce que ça consiste à
lisez quelqu'un qui a plus de 55 ans en
lui disant nous est temps de travailler
vous prenez l'emploi d'un jeune parce
que désolé opposés ainsi les générations
ne me semble pas une bonne voie pour la
cohésion de notre société et notamment
le lien entre les générations
al'inverse le tutorat est un dispositif
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'il nous
permet de financer l'emploi d'un senior
et d'organiser l'emploi pour un jeune on
finance en partie et on prend en charge
le salaire d'un senior à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise en échange de quoi le
seigneur prend sous son aile des jeunes
et qu'il va former auquel il va
transmettre son savoir faire
ça a été expérimenté notamment avec le
soutien des partenaires sociaux dans des
entreprises comme michelin ou ça permet
à la fois de valoriser toute la carrière
et tout le déroulé de carrière qui est
fait par un seigneur dans une entreprise
et en même temps de préparer l'insertion
des jeunes avec un taux d'insertion et
de maintien dans l'entreprise
bien plus élevé vous me permettrez de
penser que c'est quand même une approche
plus intelligente qui permet à la fois
de garder un senior dans l'emploi et de
préparer l'emploi d'un jeune aujourd'hui
ce dispositif concerne deux cent mille
personnes et le but dans le prolongement
du projet de loi sur les retraites
consiste à majorer les plafonds de prise
en charge des frais pour les tuteurs
dans le cadre de contrats de
professionnalisation ou d'apprentissage
enfin pour continuer à porter le fer sur
le changement des pratiques dans le
cadre de l'expérimentation qui a été
fait par nicole notât
nous voulons continuer à mutualiser au
maximum les bonnes pratiques sur le
terrain pour valoriser les entreprises
qui jouent le jeu et à linverse porter
le fer sur celles qui continuent à avoir
des pratiques consistant à sacrifier
l'emploi des seniors je pense vraiment
que c'est une cause d'intérêt général
sur laquelle on peut tous se retrouver
je ne crois pas que qui que ce soit ici
puis souhaiter continuer à sacrifier
l'emploi des plus de 55 ans il n'y a pas
de fatalité
la france était une anomalie en europe
les autres pays et des pays avec un
modèle social très performant et souvent
d'ailleurs sous l'impulsion de
gouvernement de tendance politique très
différente aussi bien en allemagne en
danemark en suède ont lutté pour élever
le taux d'emploi des seniors et on
s'aperçoit qu'ils y sont parfaitement
arrivé tout en améliorant le taux
d'emploi des femmes donc je crois
vraiment la matière on a pas mal d'idées
reçues à secouer beaucoup a été fait au
cours des trois dernières années on a
des premiers résultats tombent
qui montre que c'est parfaitement
possible il nous reste encore à étoffer
l'édifice et a continué collectivement
et je dis bien collectivement à se
battre pour faire en sorte que les
seniors se sont soutenus par l'ensemble
de la classe politique
il ya un sondage d'ailleurs qu'il sortit
en la matière qui est très intéressant
où les seniors disent on a l'impression
de kourou la classe politique quand on a
plus de 55 ans doit pas travailler
eh bien je pense que c'est ce message de
mobilisation globale qui montre qu'on
doit pouvoir arriver à soutenir
collectivement l'emploi des seniors
merci monsieur le ministre ne s'est
exposé très précis et je vais passer la
parole à nos collègues en commençant par
notre rapporteur dominique leclerc
et puis mes autres collègues me font
signe pour poser des questions oui merci
madame la présence monsieur le ministre
on convient de vous écoutent avec
attention vous avez rappelé donc dans un
premier temps toutes les mesures qui ont
été prises par le gouvernement ces
dernières années et aussi avec les
résultats malgré la crise qu'a connue le
taux d'emploi essentiellement des
seniors donc pour rester un tout petit
peu sur ce chapitre avant de parler de
l'article 32 du projet de loi
je voudrais vous mentez sur la dernière
disposition que nous avons adoptées lors
du plfss 2009 je crois qui concerne donc
cette obligation sinon il y as pénalité
vous l'avez rappelé des entreprises de
présenter des projets allant vers une
prise en compte des dispositions tous
deux mois allant vers la prise en compte
donc deux du maintien des seniors dans
l'entreprise ce qui aurait intéressant
pour nous c'était de savoir un petit peu
le suivi l'évaluation et le suivi des
mesures qui sont proposés donc dans tous
ces accords d'entreprise
il faudrait que ce soit effectif au delà
de l'acompte de la concrétisation d'un
accord
c'est la première question maintenant
pour revenir à l'article 32 projet de
loi vous l'avez dit prévoit encore
d'insister donc sur l'embauché des
seniors mais notamment ceux qui ont
perdu leur emploi
on aurait aimé que vous nous préciser un
petit peu
sous quelle forme ça va se passer car ça
fera l'objet je crois d'un décret en
conseil d'état
donc on aimera un petit peu à voir les
modalités donc de cette mesure
et aussi comment vous en avez évalué le
coût maintenant je voudrais revenir sur
un propos qu'on avait justement dans le
cadre de l'amex lorsqu'on avait évoqué
l'ensemble des façons de quitter le
monde du travail est apparue ces
derniers temps la rupture
conventionnelle alors là aussi on a peu
de recul mais il serait pour nous
intéressant d'en connaître les premières
des premiers impactés ce qui nous
interpelle aussi c'est de savoir à
savoir qu'elle ne soit pas détournée de
son objet aussi est-ce que de la suite
d'une rupture conventionnelle est ce qu
il yal un départ en retraite en pré
retraite ou aussi une inscription pour
l'emploi donc
ça sera intéressant de se donne de
connaître un petit peu votre
appréciation sur ''le octobre
quand je vois que cette rupture
conventionnelle qui serait utilisé
peut-être ou tout du moins détournée par
rapport à son objet on avait parlé d'
harmoniser des mesures fiscales et
sociales à l'occasion de toute nature le
mise en retraite
chômage et cetera tel qu'il peut y avoir
quand on quitte le monde de l'entreprise
c'est la deuxième question
troisième question c'est la rolls
dispositif de retraite progressive c'est
un dispositif qui connaît très peu de
succès parce que à notre avis est que
ces conditions d'accès limite son
attractivité si je puis dire
et pourtant je pense que ça correspond
totalement au souhait d'aider des
seigneurs à savoir quitter
progressivement le monde du travail
c'était dire en ayant une juxtaposition
d'un salaire parce qu'elle avec un
montant de pension parce qu'elle est là
vous le savez des années je croise et
2005 2006 était notre président
du sénat qui était en charge à l'époque
de l'emploi qui avait commencé à
proposer des dispositions qui elles
aussi n'ont pas eu le succès escompté il
y avait un contrat pour ses seniors un
contrat à durée déterminée dits seniors
avec la possibilité de le renouveler
mais là encore je pense qu'il était
sûrement trop rigide dans son concept et
je crois que là encore il faudrait dans
le cette notion de retraite progressive
ou
de participation des seniors que ce soit
sous forme de tutorat ou de leur place
dans l'entreprise mettre en place des
contrats de travail qui soit peut-être
plus dans la lignée du contrat précédent
dès l'instant que il ya une négociation
sur le poste de travail ça dure et il
peut être pourquoi pas d'un salaire tout
ça dans des conditions peut-être en
rupture avec le passé pourrait permettre
à mon avis d'avoir une certaine
attractivité dans ces contrats à durée
déterminée
plus spécifiquement orientée vers les
seniors alors aussi oui une autre
réflexion qui se fait jour actuellement
c'est là vers le joie entre la rupture
donc avec le monde du travail et la
possibilité de partir en retraite je
sais que dans son intervention l'autre
jour le premier ministre a dit que ça
serait peut-être vue par les partenaires
sociaux dans le cadre de l'unedic
là est bien un vide qui actuellement
interpelle les uns les autres et qui
sera sûrement l'objet d'un débat dans
les semaine prochaine au sénat lors du
passage du projet de loi et enfin autre
sujet qui nous tient que ray pour faire
bref vous êtes les ministres de l'emploi
vous savez qu'en france on a quand même
hein
sion
je crois qu'effectivement il ya un
consensus qui peut s'établir sur le fait
qu'il faut employer les seniors qu'il
faut employer des jeunes
on est tous d'accord autour de ça
malheureusement on ne va pas dans ce
sens là merci annie david marsh
il y avait trop de boutons oui ce sera
monsieur ministres juste en complément
de ce que ce qui a déjà été dit par
rapport aux mesures que vous nous avez
présenté notamment le tutorat et toutes
ces choses là il me semble que même le
cumul emploi-retraite tout cela
s'adresse également aux salariés
comment dire cad n'est plus fort mais en
tout cas parce que imaginer à
à au delà de 55 ans et en plus je
reprends aussi ce qu'a dit mon collègue
sur le fait de dire que c'est criminel
d'opposer les gens au delà de 55 ans et
les jeunes on a évidemment on est pour
que chacun puisse travailler jusqu'à 60
ans mais 60 ans voilà donc là où moi je
pose là les seniors comme vous dites
avec les jeunes c'est quand vous fait
travailler des gens au delà de 60 ans et
que leur leur capacité à prendre leur
retraite est pleine et entière et qu'il
pourrait tout à fait s'arrêter à 60 ans
et là effectivement pour moi c'est pas
une bonne solution que de continuer à
faire travailler des salariés qui ont
déjà eu bien assez de leurs 40 années de
cotisation et qui n'est pas la peine
d'en rajouter donc moi je pense que sur
cette histoire de comment dire de
tutorat et de tout ce que vous nous avez
présenté tous les salariés ne pourront
pas prétendre à ce type de à ce type de
mesures
on parlait aussi des ruptures
conventionnelles je voudrais juste vous
citer un exemple
caterpillar 600 salariés licenciés
maintenant ils font appel à ceux qui ont
été licenciés il ya quelques temps mais
qui ont plus de 50 ans effectivement et
ils les font revenir dans la dans
l'entreprise mais en tant qu'intérimaire
donc là aussi monsieur le ministre je
pense que avant 2 avant de mettre en
place des mesures incitatives
fiscalement parlant
faisons en sorte que les entreprises ne
se débarrasse pas de leur sel de leurs
salariés quand ils sont dans
l'entreprise qu'ils aient 55 55 ans ou
moins parce que quand on voit
aujourd'hui les plans de licenciements à
tels qu'ils existent dans le pays
je pense véritablement que
avant de mettre des mesures pour faire
réembaucher des gens avec des avantages
fiscaux pour les entreprises maintenant
l'emploi
quand il peut être maintenue et dans
beaucoup de cas en tout cas c'est ses
plans de licenciements pourraient être
évités donc voilà c'était juste 7
c'est pas vraiment une question monsieur
ministre mais une interrogation plus sur
les propositions que vous faites
sincèrement je je ne pense pas qu'elles
qu'elles permettront aux seniors de
garder leur emploi et ce qui m'importe
c'est bien ça c'est qu'ils puissent
garder leur emploi jusqu'à l'âge de la
retraite sans être obligé ensuite de
passer par des mesures incitatives
fiscalement parlant évidemment
intéressante pour les entreprises mais
qui font puis au final
monsieur le ministre que ces salariés là
eh ben vous disiez que c'était criminels
d'opposer les anciens les seniors et les
jeunes moi je trouve que c'est humiliant
de dire que pour embaucher qu'un
maintien au delà de 55 ans il faut
mettre des mesures fiscales derrière
parce qu'à 55 ans on est tout à fait
capable de travailler et les mesures que
vous proposez si elles ne sont pas
criminels en tout cas elles sont ce que
j'aurai enfin de mon point de vue
humiliante pour les salariés concernés
alors christiane demontès gisèle printz
jacky le menn et puis les autres qui
souhaiteront prendre la parole
christiane demontès oui monsieur le
ministre vous nous avez redis avec votre
volontarisme habituel en tout cas dans
le discours ce que vous nous aviez dit
lorsqu'on vous avez auditionné mais
c'est normal dans le cadre de l'amex
dans notre rapport sur sur les retraites
oui il ya d'ailleurs quelques petites
évolutions pas toujours positives dans
les chiffres que vous nous avez donné
aujourd'hui est ce que vous nous aviez
donné en avril
je pense aux accords de branche parce
que vous ne nous aviez dit à l'époque
qu'il y en avait 90 qui avait été qu'ils
étaient prêts à signer alors que là vous
nous donner un chiffre inférieur
bon on va pas mais vous nous avez de 80
à aujourd'hui à ben bon je vais pas
mais gottex que voir l'expression sur
les chiffres moi j'avais au delà des
préoccupations qui ont été exprimées par
par les collègues
trois questions assez précises à vous
poser vous parlez des seniors comme si
c'était des travailleurs asexué je
voudrais savoir ce que vous comptez
faire pour l'emploi des seniors femmes
qui sont encore davantage touchés par
ces problèmes là que les leurs collègues
masculins
je voudrais aussi vous poser une
question pour en prolonger la question
de ma collègue patricia sillage et sur
les mesures de tutorat dans les
paiements et comment ça marche
et quel salarié ça concerne annie david
d'isère les cadres mais il n'ya pas que
les cats qui ont des choses haha
transféré en termes de compétences donc
je voudrais que vous nous donner des
précisions
et puis on parle de l'emploi des seniors
vous avez dit le chômage des seniors est
plutôt inférieur à la moyenne nationale
dont acte je voudrais savoir mais
peut-être pouvez pas vous pouvez vous
pas nous le dire tout de suite
quelle est la part des plus de 50 ans
bénéficiaires du rsa ou 55 ans merci
gisèle printz wim où je voulais parler
justement de des femmes on a un peu près
c'est d'aimer ça fait rien voulu
enfoncer le clou à ce qu on parle de
l'emploi des jeunes des seniors et des
femmes
normalement on devrait pas parler de
faire le distinguo entre hommes et
femmes c'est tous des travailleurs mais
malheureusement c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe
et j'aimerais savoir ce que vous allez
faire pour qu'ils aient l'égalité
salariale
parce que hier j'en ai parlé
cette équipe des gens le medef l'année
qui m'a dit qui reprochait justement
qu'il y avait trop de lois concernant le
l'égalité salariale
alors j'ai fait la remarque s'il ya
beaucoup de leur égalité salariale c'est
parce que l'entreprise l'appliquent pas
andrei la patron il n'a pas apprécié
alors voilà n'est que sur du lait vous
posez merci jacky le menn
mais monsieur chemise rayée tous les
politiques ont besoin de balayer devant
leurs portes cette année c'est de faire
aussi mais bon on aimerait être
accompagné par
tu auras on a d'epargne expérimentés
comptent sur leur coupait jeunes qui
sont contraints d'apprendre
canalisations fils a donc devoir
républicain je ne peux que le respecter
ménagés marine
taux d'échec diminue considérablement
donc on a une voix qui est intéressante
cirque on voit que quand on a un jeune
et notamment sur les quartiers en
difficulté qui est pris sous sa coupe à
un salarié plus expérimentés dans lequel
il est en général un lien de confiance
qui s'établit en baisse de façon
considérable au taux de rupture et
d'échec des contrats d'alternance dont
classe et c'est quelque chose que je
trouve intéressant et sur lequel on ad
on a des moyens développés
je reprendrai pas les les questions dany
david mais je vous en parlerai
directement sur celles qui ont été
faites par sur la question fait par
christiane demontès d'abord sur le taux
de chômage des seniors est aidée et des
femmes par opposition aux taux de
chômage chez les hommes il ya une légère
divergence mais qui est très faible
on a un taux de chômage des seniors
hommes qui est autour de 6 po 2 6% et on
a un taux de chômage des seniors femmes
qui est entre 6,1 et 6 2%
donc en fait l'écart est très faible
mais cela étant il y a un écart et on
doit continuer à travailler sur ce sujet
là on n'a pas une divergence qui soit
profonde ou totalement avec un écart qui
est très important et j'ai tendance à
penser que l'évolution notamment de la
configuration des emplois va être plutôt
favorable aux femmes notamment de plus
de 50 ans est ce qu'on constate c'est
qu'on a eu un effet de rattrapage depuis
dix ans avec une amélioration du taux de
chômage chez les femmes
qui donc les rapproche maintenant
vraiment de la moyenne sur le tutorat
dans les pme qui revient pas puisque
j'en ai parlé et la part des 55 ans dans
le rsa je suis désolé mais là j'ai pas
d'informations précises mais on pourra
vous le vous le donner je pense que ça
répondra également aux questions qui ont
été posées par six et lé prince sur la
question des femmes
s'agissant de l'égalité salariale comme
vous l'avez souligné c'est vrai qu'on a
secoué le medef avec un certain nombre
de dispositifs destinés à renforcer
l'égalité salariale
je pense qu'il ne faut pas lâcher en la
matière ça fait partie des vrais
inéquité dans notre pays avec l'inéquité
vous me permettrez de l'ajouter sur
l'espérance de vie
là pour le coup les hommes sont vraiment
victime d' une inéquité face à la vie
qui est très dur à supporter
alors monsieur le mail sur votre
intervention sur la proportion sur le
taux d'emploi des 20 30 ans le taux
d'emploi des 20 30 ans est meilleur en
allemagne qu'en france
par contre là vous avez raison c'est que
ça se corrige à partir de 30 ans
pourquoi parce qu'en fait la france a
concentré à l'excès son emploi sur les
30 50 ans elle a délaissé les 20 30 ans
et elle a délaissé les plus de 50 ans et
j'ai tendance à penser même si c'est
assez
sans doute politiquement incorrect qu'
il vaut mieux qu'on ait un taux d'emploi
qu'ils soient répartit harmonieusement
toutes générations confondues
sinon on perd beaucoup sur les jeunes
générations avec des générations
sacrifiées au début et à linverse des
seniors qu'il perçoit vraiment comme
étant une profonde injustice sur l'accès
au marché du travail
je crois que c'est dans ce sens là qu'on
doive ans oui je l'avais noté sur la
feuille d'après merci beaucoup de me le
rappeler
et j'ai pas répondu non plus à la
question de monsieur godefroy sur les
travailleurs en différents ça
m'intéresse beaucoup que vous ayez poser
cette question parce que j'étais en
début de semaine avec tout un réseau d
ath avec lesquels on a travaillé
on a crise et notamment au moment où ils
ont été victimes de la crise de la
sous-traitance et en même temps pour
travailler sur l'insertion en milieu
ordinaire qu'est ce qu'on constate deux
tendances
d'abord la première les structures qui
s'occupait de travail pour les personnes
en situation de handicap ont été
fragilisés par la crise et notamment la
sous traitance
il faut qu'on les aide à se redéployer
sur d'autres secteurs par exemple chez
moi dans mon département
on était traditionnellement sur une sous
traitance industrielle on a essayé
d'évoluer vers des métiers de service et
notamment des cantines pour les grandes
administrations publiques et les
collectivités locales ce qui permet
d'aider des travailleurs en situation de
handicap à se repositionner et à éviter
de perdre un accès à l'emploi
la deuxième chose qu'on voit quand même
c'est qu'avec les lois qui ont été
adoptées la pression sur les employeurs
pour être plus attentif à l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap est
plus importante
et donc on a une fenêtre qui s'ouvre
mais qui se prépare et notamment sur le
milieu ordinaire je pense qu'on a une
possibilité d'aller plus loin mais à
condition de le préparer et de ne pas
envoyer des personnes handicapées au
massacre
le l'insertion en milieu ordinaire ça se
prépare ça se prépare avec les équipes
ça se prépare par de la formation en
amont ça se prépare par un suivi du
temps et
un taux de réussite de la bascule vers
le milieu ordinaire si c'est juste dire
allez on bascule vers le milieu
ordinaire sans qui aucune préparation
l'échec est au rendez vous il ya un
travail remarquable qui a été fait par
les esat sur la région bretonne sur
lequel on s'inspire pour essayer de
travailler avec eux pour voir comment
diffuser le travail de fond qui a été
fait et qui me semble très très
intéressent donc c'est quelque chose sur
lequel on a on a des évolutions
intéressantes
enfin monsieur le sénateur godefroy sur
l'auto entrepreneur de façon générale je
pense que l'on doit travailler sur tout
ce qui est la formation et tout ce qui
permet de solidifier le plus vite
possible les auto entrepreneurs puisque
le but ce n'est pas de rester
durablement dans le système d'auto
entrepreneur mais ensuite de pouvoir
basculer sur un chiffre d'affaires qui
permet d'être sur une entreprise pérenne
avec le paiement de charges et
l'abondement et des régimes sociaux
qu'on travaille sur ce sujet avec hervé
novelli notamment sur l'accompagnement
terme de formation un tout petit regret
de patricia sillage et mon intervention
bien sur l'apprentissage et puis les
retraites
je sais que vous avez comme le dit
toujours à coeur l'apprentissage
pourquoi quand pendant l'apprentissage
on retient qu'un trimestre pendant
l'apprentissage pour les cotisations de
retraite mais on ne peut pas un peu
augmenté puisque de 16 ans jusqu à part
presque à 22 ans fait en alternance
souvent on commence par un c ap un bac
pro ou un bts mais c'est toujours en
alternance et qui a qu'un trimestre qui
est retenu sur les 4 est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas à retenir plus deux
trimestres et qui compta contrer compte
justement pour le futur jeu neuf
propositions
donc on est en train de travailler
dessus donc avec une un travail plus
structurelle sur ce qui est l'alternance
la première étape c'est être sauvées
l'internet dans la crise la deuxième
c'est de conforter vraiment on s'attaque
à un développement de l'alternance dans
des nouveaux métiers
c'est une proposition intéressante on
peut je peux le regarder dans le cadre
de notre travail bien pas d'autres
questions
merci beaucoup chers collègues et
monsieur le ministre de toutes ces
réponses précises
merci beaucoup d'être venu jusqu'à nous
répondre à toutes nos questions
merci à vous surtout vous venez
d'assister à l'audition de laurent
wauquiez le secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'emploi sur le projet de loi portant
réforme des retraites
prochain rendez-vous 16h30 avec les
auditions de force ouvrière et de la cgt
toujours sur le même sujet vous pouvez
retrouver toutes nos auditions en vidéo
et bien sûr tous nos décryptage de
l'actualité parlementaire sur notre site
www.publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur notre chaîne